[Music]
welcome to Koch news Doctor Strange 3
will probably be released sooner than
expected DC denies the alleged work on
Wonder Woman 3 and Rapunzel will
probably be the next Disney remake well
a great opportunity to talk about the
snow white storm this and more
awaits you on this week's keynote check
news there's been no end to the hatred
since the announcement of Disney's
remake of Snow White there has been a
hail of criticism now leading actress
Rachel zler is once again being the
focus of hostility criticism often
centers on the casting of actress Rachel
zegler who due to her Colombian Roots
would not have the snow white skin color
that defines the character now follows
another round of accusations many are
reproaching the actress of despising the
original story and thus being unsuitable
for the role a video from 2022 is
circulating on the web in which the
actress was critical of the animated
version zler told Entertainment Weekly
at the time that she was not a fan of
the original in an interview with
variety she pointed out that the
original was a product of 1937 and that
some things would thus be done
differently for instance Snow White is
no longer being rescued by a prince she
also no longer dreams of true love but a
following in her late Father's Footsteps
as a leader she told Extra TV that she
found the original aen parts as it
focused too much on the Love Story
between Snow White and the prince who
would lit stalk her the actress added
however that as a small child she was
once frightened by a ride at Disney
World and therefore no longer dared to
watch the animated film as a result
videos are currently making the rounds
on Tik Tok that take her statements out
of context and accuse her of outright
hating the story likewise Ziggler's
participation in the actor strike caused
resentment in which the actress
explicitly turned against her employer
Disney she said if I'm going to stand
there 18 hours in a dress of an iconic
Disney princess then I deserve to get
paid for every hour that it streamed
online here zler addresses the core
demand of the strikers namely a more
just payment in the era of streaming
exploitation this new storm is
likely to meet with little reaction from
Disney after all this is not the first
time that the company has had to put up
with hostility in response to its
liveaction adaptations of well-known
Disney princesses Disney is consciously
pursuing the strategy of Reviving old
stories in a more contemporary and
diverse guys the remake of The Little
Mermaid has likewise been met with
accusations based on the color of the
actress's skin Snow White will be
released in theaters on March 24th 2024
what do you guys think about the remakes
of famous Disney Classics let's have a
good discussion in the
comments the back and forth around the
Wonder Woman sequel goes on and on
barely was Wonder Woman 3 confirmed by
leading actress galado do everything is
now different again according to
multiple sources at DC the project is
not in the works
contrary to gau's statements since the
Takeover of DC by James gun and Peter
saffron the future of Wonder Woman was
considered unsure first the project was
canceled under the new director of Patty
Jenkins then galado recently stated that
the movie was in development with her
gun and saffron had assured her that she
was in the best hands that they would
develop Wonder Woman 3 with her and that
she had nothing to worry about naturally
it's a bitter pill to swallow when this
is directly denied by DC apparently the
DC bosses don't even have plans for
another sequel this news was first
reported by kider and then confirmed by
several trade magazines except for
Paradise Lost a prequel series at HBO
Max there will be no notable Wonder
Woman projects in the near future the
character will of course appear in the
DCU again at some point after all she is
a regular part of the Justice League
however an appearance by galado seems
doubtful at the moment the actress did
Express her continued interest in the
role still it remains uncertain whether
she will will actually be cast in it the
example of Henry cabala Superman shows
that being interested in returning
doesn't always go hand inand with
actually being cast fans can
nevertheless look forward to the prequel
series Paradise Lost unlike the solo
movies the series has a set plan and
will introduce us to the island of
themira where the mighty Amazon live the
plot takes place long before the most
famous Amazon is
born Doctor Strange is likely to make
his return sooner than expected
according to Rumors in Doctor Strange 3
he will lay The crucial groundwork for
the further Avengers movies in 2022
Marvel released the second part of its
Doctor Strange film series and achieved
financial success starring Benedict
Cumberbatch Doctor Strange 2 was
particularly appealing due to its horror
Direction and set a completely new tone
in the MCU of course this is probably
also due to director Sam Ry who shaped
the genre with his Evil Dead movies and
was seen as the perfect choice for the
sequel part two ended with a cliffhanger
where we see dror strange grow a third
eye on his forehead since then fans have
been eagerly awaiting further
appearances of the popular character and
a possible sequel this now seems to
happen in the near future the website
the cosmic circus which is a reliable
source of information regarding Marvel
has reported that a third installment
could be in the works fairly soon and
that's not all the movie is supposed to
set things up for Avengers 5 and
Avengers 6 and is based on a very
specific comic book that should be well
known to connoisseurs the talk is of
time runs out the comic series focuses
on the Battle of various Avengers teams
against these so-called incursions which
have already been mentioned frequently
in the MCU movies these are multiversal
catastrophes in which several universes
collide with each other in the comic
series written by Jonathan Hickman
almost all realities are wiped out by
incursions however since the movie is
primarily another doctor strange
Adventure the character is likely to be
given more emphasis than the other
superheroes of course the new main
villain Kang is responsible for the
decay of the universe however the cosmic
circus is speculating on whether he will
also appear as a variant in the film
specific information on the production
of Doctor Strange 3 is sadly not yet
known the progress will depend like so
many others on how the current situation
around the strikes in Hollywood will
develop in the coming weeks or months
we'll keep you updated as
always there's no end in sight Disney
continues to devote its attention to
liveaction adaptations of its animated
class
this time it'll be a successful movie
that is actually not all that old in
addition to the filming of Snow White
with Rachel zler in the leading role and
galado as the evil stepmother Disney is
now tackling the next remake project
it's rumored that the company is
planning a liveaction adaptation of
tangle which kicked off a new era of
computer animated Disney princesses in
2010 according to Hollywood insiders the
company is already looking at a very
specific actress who could play Rapunzel
the talk is of Florence pew who is
considered one of Hollywood's very big
talents the Oscar animated actress has
already featured in Christopher Nolan's
open Heimer this year and is also part
of the upcoming science fiction epic
Dune part two so she has plenty of
experience and acting Talent whether Pew
herself is interested in the role though
is not known it also remains unclear if
and when the movie will be released
however the next Disney remake is bound
to result in heated discussions one way
or
another trash fans listen up legendary
pictures has given us a first look at
the reboot of the trash classic the
Toxic Avenger this time game of thron
star Peter Dinklage will embody the
Monstrous hero the trash movie The Toxic
Adventure released in 1984 tells the
story of Melvin who was completely
deformed by an accident involving
radioactive waste and therefore fights
the evil of his city as the Toxic
Avenger Alias toxy the film is one of
the great Classics of its genre and it's
still considered the mascot of the
independent film Film Production Company
troma where James gun gained his first
experiences as a director and
screenwriter since the franchise has
been around for a few years now the
announcement of a planned reboot might
come as a bit of a surprise the image
shows Dinklage wielding a bright green
Mop as a weapon and standing in the
frame of a kicked in door likewise a
poster was published showing the film's
logo directed by mon Blair the movie
presents us with Peter Dinklage as well
as other well-known names such as Jacob
Trembley Kevin Bacon Elijah Wood and
Julia Davis who will all be part of the
cast The eagerly anticipated reboot will
celebrate its Premiere at Fantastic Fest
in Texas and should just like its
predecessors convinced with plenty of
violence and
disgust now it's your turn which of our
topics affected you the most this week
let us know in the comments and if
you're still looking for more content
check out our new Keno original in which
we introduce you to Marvel's
Thunderbolts thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week with more Koch
news
[Music]